who's your favorite rapper ever
my favorite rapper is probably
it's weird because i have i like
different rappers for different reasons
because i'm not like give me three of
them uh andre 3000 biggie wayne
all elite
you know see just different reasons well
what's okay give me the reason for each
one
well 100 000 is like storytelling
and like how it like
it be sounded like he's just talking
facts
like he just he's just talking telling a
story and it's like eric just what's
your favorite outcast album
i don't have a favorite outcast album
you know what's so crazy i like feature
andre 3000 better than i like
album
oh yeah you're wildin i understand you
and i understand why people would would
argue with that too
you you've listened to equipment eye
bro just i've listened to a lot of his
music okay i just want to make sure that
i really like
i'm like man i love that walk it out
remix that dj unkverse man that [ __ ] was
crazy like well have you heard of
criminal nah
nah there's certain artists where it's
like features they just kind of just be
wow you give them 16 in the topic and
they just
dude that kanye andre song that didn't
come out on donda would have been the
best song on donda did you hear that
record that leaked i did
i thought that [ __ ] was gas
actually it was a great andre verse that
just was i was like [ __ ] man
that was that was that was a you know
saying an interesting decision by kanye
it was a terrible decision
maybe because maybe the album did what
it did because of the
the final product that it came out you
know what though i appreciate about
kanye is like
you never know we might wake up tomorrow
and he'll be like i added seven new
songs to donda
and all everything and it's everything
we wanted